[Music]
today's question comes from ahmet in
michigan i'm 30 years old i work for a
local credit union and we get quarterly
reviews i've met expectation for my next
review and i've upped my skill set i
want to ask for a sizable raise
after working really hard during the
lockdown where half of my team worked
remotely during that time one co-worker
and i have been in the office whenever
it was open and i recently found out
that one of my co-workers is making 15
to 17 000 more than me and when this
person takes time off i'm responsible
for making sure their tasks get done the
only person who knows how much i work
uh how much work i put in is my manager
i currently work over 60 hours a week
i do love my job in the company i'm
working for but it is hard when i know
i'm putting in more work than everyone
else and getting paid less
well we've heard this question before
and unfortunately this the psychology
around this kind of information that
you've gotten is really hard to overcome
because you are now aware and you are
comparing yourself and that is a very
dangerous dangerous place to be in
because you can't do much about this in
this situation when you go into your
next review uh you know
leveraging this information isn't going
to help you i wouldn't do it what i
would talk about is a growth plan i
would lay out
how much you love the company as you as
you put in this email and that you want
to be here and you want to grow not just
professionally but financially but you
lead with professional growth what are
some areas that i can get better in
where i'm a little bit weak what are
some skills some tools i can add to my
tool belt
that will allow me to a get more
responsibility drive greater value b and
then c grow financially as well that's
the posture by which you approach this
so that your leaders get some buy-in
they see your hunger but also your
humility and uh that's all you can do
and if you've got healthy leadership
they're going to respond and they're
going to talk about a growth plan and
then measure the growth that's tied to
compensation if they are not going to
address this and they kick the can down
the road this is a sign
that it may be time for you to move on
and where you see a ladder and not a lid
yeah that's the thing and so there is
nothing wrong with saying
in my mind and you can correct me ken um
how can i add value that will make you
want to give me more money because i'd
like to see some more income but i i
want to be worth it yes
instead of i deserve this because so and
so that's right if you say i did i
deserve this because 60 hours i deserve
this because so and so you know the
entitlement i deserve this thing
um
is uh one of the most negative possible
emotions
uh that you can that you can generate
and you've gotten yourself kind of down
in that hole a little bit here yeah a
little bit of a pity party going on in
the email there oh sure and uh and
rightly so but still you know
it's the wrong posture for you to get
ahead you're not supposed to know what
your co-worker makes
and this is why
because it's almost impossible to not
deal positively with that and that's why
i laid it out when you sit with your
leader you don't ask for a raise you ask
for a growth plan you lead with as you
notice what i said first where can i get
better what are some areas where you
think i can how can i add value that
once makes you want to give me if some
i'm not i mean i own ramsey solutions if
you come in my office and i'm doing a
review with you or whatever or we're
talking or even you just came in
randomly and said listen
i i'd like to make more money and
uh the way i want to do that is i want
to be worth more how can i be worth more
how can i add value versus i actually
had a guy come in my office many years
ago had more degrees than a thermometer
overeducated fool
and said uh you know
show me his resume you know a guy like
me that has this many degrees
uh we usually make like a lot more than
i make now
and i said well you know you're working
a small business son and he said what do
you mean i said well small business
works like this your raise is effective
when you are
i don't give a crap about your degrees
when you do something i'll share it with
you
that's how it works in a small business
but but you know i got a degree so i got
or i got six degrees so you know what
are you a black belt yeah i mean come on
no
so um that didn't that doesn't that
didn't play in dave's office no and it
won't play anybody else's either by the
way exactly right not because i'm a jerk
it's just that's the way it is